[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
uno de los grandes retos que tiene ahora
mismo la política planetaria cómo
conjugar transición ecológica y justicia
social una asociación complicada para
ello nos acompaña en este estudio xavi
en granada un periodista independiente
que especializada en latinoamérica
bienvenida saben bailar buenos días
olivier urrutia politólogo y asesor en
management político bienvenido alivien
hola buenos días lorena torres
bernardino en dúplex desde lyon es
investigadora del instituto de ciencias
políticas de lyon enfocada en cuestiones
del agua lorena buenos días hola buenos
días
transición ecológica y justicia social
una asociación complicada hoy nuestro
asunto en primera plana
[Música]
de las macro granjas a los vuelos 'low
cost' pasando por la factura de la luz
casi todos los debates que podemos
encender en nuestra sociedad actual más
aún si cabe desde el estallido de la
pandemia tienen un transfondo en el
trasfondo una ecuación no resuelta que
se ha convertido en la clave de
cualquier laboratorio político cómo
conjugar transición ecológica con
justicia social aunque el origen de la
comey 19 siga dispersando dudas lo que
ha quedado nítido con esta crisis es que
la gente no sólo necesitaba médicos y
hospitales elementos básicos de
cualquier sistema de atención sanitaria
sino también agua limpia aire puro y
vivienda elementos básicos de cualquier
política medioambiental bien
estructurada el agua ha sido declarada
un derecho humano por la onu pero el
aire todavía no lo es y en todo el mundo
millones de personas mueren
prematuramente
por falta de aire limpio como hacemos
para no agrandar las desigualdades y que
ser ecologista no sea un privilegio de
quien pueda pagárselo repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja este gran asunto
tan esencial en la política actual
revista los dedica este número a como el
cambio climático ya ha cambiado a
francia ya no es un futurible sino algo
que afecta el día a día ciudadano
revista nikkei asia otro ejemplo de lo
que hablamos hoy la adicción asiática al
hábito de quemar carbón cómo eliminarlas
se pregunta la publicación la revista
sin transición dedica este número a la
democracia alimentaria otro ángulo
ligado al tema jugando con el lema
francés libertad igualdad y bien comer
se pregunta esta otra portada del kuga
decanter nacional dedicada al movimiento
de los chalecos amarillos un enfado
francés y sobre todo un ejemplo que
representa de lo que hoy hablamos
recuerden que la mecha aprendió con el
aumento del precio de los carburantes en
regiones de francia que no tienen
facilidades de transporte pero tenemos
ejemplos infinitos encima de la mesa
vamos a hablar de algunos de ellos pero
antes saben estamos ante el gran desafío
de la política actual sí creo que es
realmente un gran desafío porque esa
transición energética
consume también muchos minerales que
vamos a necesitar de aquí al año 2050
por ejemplo se estima que va a crecer la
demanda por litro por cobalto y por
otros minerales que necesitamos para
construir fábricas las baterías
eléctricas esa demanda va a crecer de
450 por ciento a nivel mundial
oliver parece que los políticos tienen
complicado resolver esta ecuación en td
con transición ecológica y justicia
social que emite es complicado
resolverlo sigo a menudo se parece que
se oponen las dos cosas cuando en
realidad van muy estrechamente
relacionada es decir hablar de
transición ecológica es también hablar
de justicia justicia social perdón
si los políticos
se quedan en esa oposición un poco
artificial es tanto por cobardía no en
emprender grandes cambios como por falta
yo creo de visión a largo plazo es decir
de no tener un proyecto de sociedad real
global ambicioso y entonces se quedan
con decisiones yo diría como muy
limitadas corto a la cita sí exactamente
vamos hasta lyon lorena torres
bernardino investigadora del instituto
de ciencias políticas de lyon lo vimos
en el movimiento de los chalecos
amarillos en francia parece paradójico
combinar justicia social y ecología al
menos para algunos políticos es bastante
complicado sabemos que cerrar una mina
por ejemplo de carbón significa pérdida
de empleo aunque sea mejor para el medio
ambiente luchar contra la agricultura
intensiva por poner otro ejemplo y
querer limitar la también quiere decir
restringir ingresos para los productores
cómo se puede salir de esta paradoja es
entrante una paradoja
en donde los afectados y los más
vulnerables siguen siendo los mismos hoy
y hace 30 años es decir los más pobres
los sectores más vulnerables es decir la
clase trabajadora incluso un sector
importante de la clase media como lo
vimos exactamente en francia con los
chalecos amarillos
esta paradoja plantea primero un reto
incluso
de cambio de pensamiento entre lo que
/ dejar de pelear esta parte de
la ecología con la justicia mucho contra
ponemos estos dos conceptos pero forman
parte incluso de la justicia ambiental
incluso como concebimos las necesidades
y la contaminación como salimos de esta
paradoja pues si se trata de
proteger el medio ambiente pero a través
de una regulación democrática pero esta
parte de la ecología y la justicia
social desde una perspectiva
de complementariedad y no desde una
perspectiva de desigualdad que hay
también es el reto importante en esta
paradoja estructural que está construida
a partir de desigualdades de
desigualdades que venimos arrastrando
de años
es una paradoja que se produce aquí en
europa pero también en muchos rincones
de latinoamérica también conoce muy bien
toda latinoamérica donde se ha muchos
lugares donde se han producido esa
especie de conflictos por la tensión que
supone ésta
este matrimonio entre transición
ecológica y justicia social
pero es una realidad de la que no
podemos eludir y puedo dar uno de los
ejemplos por ejemplo en
la actualidad se ve que la ciudad de
medellín de 4 millones de habitantes
hace muchos esfuerzos hacia un cambio
ecológico
construyendo un corredor verde que
atraviese toda la ciudad y es un reto
muy importante porque el tienen que
remodelar muchos barrios donde se han
amontonado casitas de forma informal y
todos esos barrios tienen que ser
remodelados tienen que re volver a
alojar a la gente en otras zonas o de
construir y es todo un reto porque a esa
gente
se las tiene que considerar
democráticamente que hacerla participar
al proceso de remodelación y
garantizarles garantizarles un
un alojamiento y una calidad de vida
mejor que antes y es todo un reto
democrático como lo decía lorena
precisamente y hay otros otros ejemplos
que son de de las industrias de los
minerales que están ahora demandada que
están pedidas por el mundo para
para producir los materiales que para
para fabricar las baterías eléctricas y
que imponen retos desafíos nuevos
pero iguales a lo de antes a las
poblaciones los locales la mayor tensión
en el quinquenio de macro se produjo
precisamente por el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos
que surgió por el aumento del precio de
los carburantes a regiones de francia
olivier donde el transporte público
había empezado a sentir carestías desde
desde hacía tiempo vamos a
acostumbrarnos de forma cada vez más
habitual este tipo de movimientos de
tensión a dos veces francia puede ser
una cosa en realidad cuando se habla de
transición es hacerlo desde el punto de
vista tanto de la justicia ecológica
como de la justicia social es decir que
no se puede exigir el mismo nivel de
esfuerzos a clases precarias que a
clases privilegiadas
no por nada aquí se habla de justicia la
noción de justicia
por otro lado también existe una
paradoja no entre ecología y justicia
sociales sino desde el punto de vista de
cómo se toman las decisiones políticas o
se emprenden
políticas públicas en este apartado
porque
cada con cada vez más frecuencia
por la presión de los desastres
medioambientales
pues los gobernantes van a tener que
emprender acciones cada vez más brutales
y radicales radicales pero exigidas por
la la urgencia
planetaria con lo cual pues por la falta
de anticipación
justamente es cuando se toman decisiones
más brutales y radicales exigidas por la
la realidad entonces si se quisiese
conciliar justicia social con justicia
medioambiental habría que tener esa gran
política pública que en realidad
conseguiría
auxiliar ambas cosas es decir por
ejemplo no pero una cosa todo el mundo
sabe perfectamente que el cambio de
paradigma de sociedad hacia una sociedad
más ecológica esto generaría muchos
empleos con lo cual habría ya que
anticipar lo formando a toda esa gente
que podría tener empleos en esta nueva
sociedad pero no se hace vamos a volver
a lyon con lorena torres porque la lucha
contra el cambio climático se ha
individualizado mucho es decir dejar de
comer carne usar bicicleta pero
precisamente en la zona con lo que decía
olivier pero muy poco en responsabilizar
a estados y a grandes empresas esto de
la acción individual frente al estado
esto puede ser la clave
lo complejo aquí quizás incluso lo
peligroso es que éstas éstas acciones
individuales o esta responsabilidad
individual esta conciencia ambiental
puede convertirse pueden convertirse en
acciones aisladas
entonces
si estas acciones no
encuentran el camino para vincularse con
acciones de carácter colectivo e incluso
de carácter público
de una acción pública más amplia corren
el peligro de no ser suficientes en
algún momento sin embargo actualmente
los gobiernos también parecen no tener
la intención de crear mecanismos de
vinculación
de acciones individuales como lo que
decía o de acción pública
e incluso coordinar los esfuerzos de la
acción colectiva como eje como
ejemplaridad es decir si tenemos
ejemplos de acciones individuales
propias como las que mencionaste de
acciones colectivas que responden más a
incluso a los conceptos de
sostenibilidad
entonces
pues si las acciones individuales pero
sin poner en riesgo de desvincular la
selección pública lo cual nos lleva a
otra pregunta si los estados pueden caer
en echar toda la carga encima del
ciudadano de a pie para evitar
responsabilizarse ellos mismos lo voy a
plantear a vuelta de pausa nos vamos
unos pequeños minutos y volvemos a
seguir adquieren primera plana hasta
ahora
[Música]
i
llega a ucrania la asistencia militar de
eeuu en medio de los temores ante una
eventual invasión rusa soldados
estadounidenses también empiezan a
aterrizar en polonia como parte del
esfuerzo de la otan y mientras tanto
bombarderos rusos con capacidad nuclear
sobrevuelan velarlos
costa rica se alista para las elecciones
de este domingo más de 3 millones de
personas están llamadas a elegir a su
nuevo presidente en medio de un complejo
panorama electoral con 25 candidatos que
generan indecisión entre los votantes
el ciclón vaciar y se acerca a
madagascar donde se espera que toque
tierra este sábado los meteorólogos
advierten que el fenómeno pueda causar
daños significativos a la nación insular
sólo dos semanas después de que una
tormenta causara la muerte de unas 55
personas
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en ucrania porque aumenta la
atención debido a la presencia de
militares estadounidenses en europa del
este- por los temores de una eventual
invasión de rusia asistencia militar
procedente de washington llegó hoy a
kiev mientras que en polonia soldados
estadounidenses empezaron a arribar como
parte de los movimientos de la otan para
poner tropas adicionales en la región
mientras tanto bombarderos rusos con
capacidad nuclear de largo alcance
sobrevolaron el cielo de belarús aliado
de moscú y vecino de ucrania lo que ha
avivado los temores de que rusia pueda
realizar un ataque desde el norte
se enviará a 1.700 soldados del ejército
de eeuu a polonia es una unidad de élite
de las fuerzas armadas debidamente
equipada y entrenada para llevar a cabo
tareas y misiones en todo el mundo
dentro de varias horas desde el anuncio
de la alerta me gustaría señalar que los
soldados de la división aerotransportada
82 son hombres con los que nuestros
soldados han cooperado muy a menudo
realizamos tareas juntos como parte de
misiones en el extranjero ya sea en irak
o en afganistán estamos también listos
para aceptar otra transferencia de
tropas estadounidenses de las fuerzas
armadas estamos esperando a ver qué pasa
en las próximas horas pasamos a francia
la ciudad de lille fue el escenario de
tensiones por la presencia del candidato
presidencial de extrema derecha eriksen
que tiene previsto realizar un acto de
campaña activistas y estudiantes de
izquierda protestaron contra el
aspirante y protagonizaron
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad que les lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos para dispersarlos de manera
paralela a una multitud de seguidores de
se move hacían largas filas para hacer
parte del evento
el presidente de turquía recep tayyip
erdogán informó a través de la red
social 'twitter' que dio positivo para
kobe 19 el islamista conservador aclaró
que sus síntomas son leves y que está
contagiado con la variante omicron por
lo que continuará con sus labores desde
casa erdogán regresó este viernes de una
visita a kiev donde se reunió con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
y austria se convirtió en el primer país
de la unión europea donde es obligatorio
vacunarse contra el kobe 19 la medida
pretende elevar la tasa de inmunización
una de las más bajas del bloque con
multas de hasta tres mil seiscientos
euros para quienes no reciban las
inyecciones quedan exentas las personas
embarazadas los menores de 18 años
las personas que o para las que la
vacuna suponga un riesgo y quienes se
hayan recuperado de la enfermedad en los
últimos 180 días así pues de hecho
desafortunadamente no hemos sido
testigos de la gran afluencia que
esperábamos es más como unas pocas gotas
de lluvia la mayoría de las personas que
vienen reciben su segunda y tercera
dosis pero aún tenemos la esperanza de
que la gente se convenza solo puedo
apelar a ellos por favor vengan y
vacunen se y costa rica el país
centroamericano que llevo 25 años de
crecimiento económico según cifras del
banco mundial ha sufrido un retroceso
debido en gran medida a la pandemia lo
que ha causado un alto desempleo y una
contracción de su economía problemas que
deberá afrontar el nuevo presidente cuya
elección empieza este domingo 6 de
febrero andrés granadillo tiene los
detalles
la peor cifra en cuatro décadas según el
banco mundial la pandemia contrajo la
economía costarricense en un 4,1 por
ciento en 2020 después de un período de
25 años de crecimiento constante siendo
estos los principales desafíos para la
nación centroamericana que se acercará a
las urnas este domingo 6 de febrero en
busca de un nuevo presidente el
candidato que ya gobernó entre 1994 y
1998 uno de los más opcionados acogerá
el cargo según las encuestas propone
alternativas por supuesto que nos vamos
a acercar a todas las organizaciones
financieras internacionales para ver en
qué podemos mejorar los acuerdos que se
hayan dejado por esta administración
otra preocupación de los tres millones y
medio de votantes registrados es el
desempleo por un porcentaje del 14,4 por
ciento es el más alto de la década
algunos culpan a la gestión del
mandatario saliente carlos alvarado y a
las dos tendencias políticas
tradicionales
unidad social cristiana y el partido de
la liberación nacional del que el iner
saborío forma parte
cuatro años no son suficientes para
solventar todo lo que no se hizo o cosas
que se hizo mal pero si nos da la
posibilidad de parar la situación de
recomponernos en todo cuanto se puede
pero además avanzar el resultado de la
votación del domingo para los 57
diputados de la asamblea unicameral del
país también es incierto con todos los
escaños en disputa está pendiente la
legislación relacionada al cumplimiento
de los términos con el fondo monetario
internacional que le proporcionará al
país 1800 millones de dólares para
solventar la crisis una situación que
aprovecha el tercer candidato favorito
fabricio han ganado nosotros queremos
renegociar conversar ya lo estamos
haciendo con el fondo para que cuando
seamos gobierno ellos sepan que nuestra
ruta si es sanear las finanzas pero no
golpeando el bolsillo de los
costarricenses según las últimas
encuestas ningún candidato alcanzará el
40 por ciento de los votos necesarios
para ganar una primera vuelta el
resultado podría definirse el 3 de abril
con un balotaje en marruecos continúan
los esfuerzos para rescatar a ryan a rne
el niño de 5 años que cayó en un pozo de
32 metros de profundidad desde el pasado
martes en el pueblo de irán ubicado en
la provincia de chefchauen los
rescatistas han usado una cámara para
monitorearlo e imágenes en medios
marroquíes muestran al menor en el fondo
del agujero y ha mencionado que es
difícil determinar cuál es su estado de
salud aún no se sabe cuánto tiempo
tomará la excavación debido a las
autoridades oa que las autoridades o las
autoridades relacionadas con las rocas y
temor ante el desplazamiento
deslizamiento de tierra
faltan dos metros para llegar a él
esperamos llegar a él sin problemas el
operativo se está realizando con
precaución en el interior hay 11
trabajadores trabajadores de protección
civil técnicos en levantamiento
topográfico trabajadores de excavación y
otros técnicos la operación se está
realizando con cautela no es posible
acabar rápido y fuerte por las grietas
en el suelo y también por la presencia
del otro pozo y después de desatar
fuertes lluvias en las islas del océano
índico mauricio y la reunión el ciclón
bats irá y se dirige ahora hacia
madagascar donde se espera que toque
tierra este sábado los meteorólogos
advierten que la tormenta podría suponer
una amenaza muy seria para los
residentes veamos con mares agitados que
ya golpean la costa oriental de
madagascar
los residentes se preparan para el
ciclón bat shirai y buscan donde pasar
la tormenta con seguridad
vivimos en una casa de madera la
reforzamos con sacos de arena pero no
estamos seguros de que aguante así que
nos vamos a ir donde unos familiares que
viven en una construcción más estable
como algunos de nuestros familiares ya
se han ido a un refugio de emergencia si
el tiempo empeora también nos iremos los
meteorólogos prevén fuertes vientos de
más de 200 kilómetros por hora y
advierten que las olas podrían alcanzar
hasta 15 metros de altura las naciones
unidas dicen haber intensificado los
esfuerzos de preparación ha ayudado a
abrir centros de evacuación y entregado
provisiones las organizaciones de
asistencia advierten que la tormenta
supone un riesgo para casi 4 millones y
medio de personas
prevemos un impacto significativo en las
poblaciones de madagascar incluso en las
zonas que aún se están recuperando de la
tormenta tropical ana a finales de enero
la tormenta tropical ana trajo fuertes
lluvias que provocaron inundaciones
generalizadas en madagascar lo que cobró
la vida de más de 50 personas y dejó a
miles sin hogar
y finalizamos en reinounido con las
imágenes de una sonriente reina isabel
segunda quien celebró el aniversario
número 70 de su ascenso al trono durante
una recepción en su residencia de
sandringham norfolk la monarca hizo una
excepcional aparición pública luego de
los rumores sobre su estado de salud y
allí compartido con personas de la
comunidad local isabel segunda se
convirtió en reina a los 25 años luego
de la muerte de su padre el rey jorge
sexto el 6 de febrero de 1952
hasta que es informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de cómo asociar la transición
ecológica con justicia social como uno
de los grandes retos políticos que
tenemos hoy en día lo hacemos con sabin
granada un periodista oliver urrutia
politólogo y lorena torres investigadora
en dúplex desde lyon antes de irnos a la
pausa estábamos hablando de la
responsabilidad estatal y las acciones
sin duda las del otro lado si los
estados pueden caer en echar toda la
carga encima del ciudadano a pie pero
también señala bolivia una cosa muy muy
importante es el cortoplacismo en este
tema es decir como la política de corto
plazo va contra el planeta porque no hay
una visión de largas miras es uno de los
problemas a los que apunta bolivia
dijo johnson y tengo un ex presidente
francés que
era el último gran presidente que iba a
tener francia porque después de él sólo
habría contables
y funcionarios es decir es exactamente
lo que estamos hablando es que en la
realidad actual exige un cambio total no
en una remuneración no un cambio total
de paradigma de paradigmas y una y para
ello se necesita una visión como medio
un cómo darnos trazo en la sociedad del
clic de la red social del impacto diario
de la crítica instantánea cómo se
conjuga eso con una visión a largo plazo
yo no soy político soy politólogo
que nos empuja al cortoplacismo pero
exigimos grandes visiones de mira y
grandes planificaciones política el
cortoplacismo también es una obligación
no tenemos que tomar distancia con
bueno con lo que consideramos como
opiniones porque si consideramos la
minería por ejemplo para extraer el
litio el cobalto que necesitamos para
fabricar las baterías
hoy en día son industrias que contaminan
a su vez contaminan porque usan cianuro
usan químicos y contaminan el agua
contaminan los suelos y entonces es como
un círculo vicioso que produce que la
transición energética a su es contamina
lo que pasa es que el cortoplacismo pero
a la vez no tenemos más remedio
alternativa hoy sino que tenemos que
profundizar la tecnología para
solucionar estos estas desventajas esas
nueva contaminación es posible les
pregunta a los dos es posible llegar a
soluciones que combinen ecología y
justicia social dentro de este sistema
que nos ha traído hasta aquí o esto sólo
es posible realizarlo desde
planteamientos antisistema por ejemplo
el decrecimiento que sería una cosa muy
antisistema es decir se pueden encontrar
soluciones dentro del propio sistema que
nos ha traído hasta este punto es una
muy buena pregunta yo no soy experto en
este tema pero
reflexionando un poco sobre la pregunta
que yo creo que es como central genera
todo esto
podría decir que a ver si se necesita
una visión y una planificación del
cambio de sociedad y del modelo
productivo
habría que preguntarse si es posible
planificar una economía liberal
y la respuesta en general es no pero a
la vez
tampoco habría que caer en una facilidad
pensando que el liberalismo es el único
problema porque si nos atenemos también
a la unión soviética y a un modelo
productivo no mucho más estatal y
planificado pues la economía y el modelo
soviéticos eran igual de malos para el
medio ambiente mediante el modelo
liberal entonces ahí sí que muchos
expertos en realidad más que yo en este
tema dicen que en realidad el problema
no es tanto el liberalismo o la economía
planificada como el crecimiento no la
ideología del crecimiento y podría ser
que la respuesta más allá del modelo de
sociedad estuviese en un modelo no más
filosófico o filosófico es decir
crecimiento contra decrecimiento pero
entonces eso nos llevaría a preguntarnos
sobre qué aspectos queremos decrecer
porque en realidad este sistema en el
qué se basa en la máxima de si quieres
algo a través del capital puedes acceder
a ello de una forma maximalista cuanto
más mejor pero lo que supone esto el
planeta nos dice ojo hay límites aunque
te lo puedas permitir no debes hacerlo
es decir algo tan antropológicamente
aceptable como asumir que hay límites lo
que pasa que es muy antisistema al mismo
tiempo lo enlazó por la cuestión
filosófica la que sólo es aprendiendo a
la vez y miren ustedes que estamos ahora
frente a una inflación
enorme del de los precios de las
energías que usamos la electricidad el
gas y nos vemos obligados precisamente a
cambiar nuestro comportamiento también
de ciudadanos frente a esa inflación les
voy a preguntar si es posible ser eco
liberal bueno más o menos va a empezar a
responder olivier no es una
contradicción el término eco liberal
como por ejemplo podríamos calificar no
si están de acuerdo al presidente macro
como él mismo se quiere calificar es una
contradicción en sí mismo
a ver lo al mero primero existe existe
una corriente y ccoo liberal
entonces eso es una radiación uno al
mismo se defina y otra cosa es que
existe que en realidad
existe pero pero
si es un oxímoron o antinómico bueno
y si tú planteas el hecho de que marco
sería único liberal pues entonces
tenemos la respuesta de que no es
suficiente para emprender el cambio que
se necesita es decir que son ajustes es
decir la ecología allí es más ajuste que
realmente lo que se necesita en cuanto a
cambio profundo de modelo de sociedad
entonces eco liberal
puede ser pero yo no creo que sea
suficiente como para enfrentarnos al
desafío mayor que nos plantea el tema
del medio ambiente voy hasta el lyon
lorena torres investigadora del
instituto de ciencias políticas de lyon
quizá la pregunta es cómo democratizar
los productos más virtuosos ejemplo la
agricultura bio sin caer en los mismos
problemas de sobreproducción
cómo hacer compatible los nuevos dos
nuevos modos de producción sostenible
con los mecanismos de producción ya
existentes y con los nuevos mecanismos
de producción y de política pública que
se deben de dar eso es la gran paradoja
y el gran reto muchos autores e incluso
propone quizás es un carácter más
filosófico político
incluso de ir más allá de lo inédito no
incluso decir que transitar incluso a
mecanismos públicos utópicos no
argumentando que lo utópico no es lo
no realizable si no lo que no se ha
realizado
entonces quizás suena un poco discursivo
esto pero tenemos que transitar hacia
hacia nuevos modos de producción inédita
como no queremos en estos problemas de
sobreproducción también hay que ver el
reto de la contaminación cruzada
que evidentemente si los sistemas de
producción más sostenibles o la
agricultura bio etcétera pero también
producen daños al suelo entonces como
podemos como alcanzamos a regular estas
estas medidas también
creo que precisamente requiere de esta
regulación un poco más democrática entre
productores consumidores y la propia
sociedad que que está alrededor de todo
esto
claro pero aquí también entra lo que es
el
la
posibilidad de ser populista de hacer
populismo con este tema porque seamos
honestos hoy en día ir a la tienda bío
en bicicleta ser un urbanita eso es un
nivel de vida es un nivel de vida que no
todo el mundo se puede se puede permitir
cuando hablamos de los vuelos low cost
ahora mismo hacer un ida y vuelta a
londres de aquellos de parís por 50
euros ahora estamos diciendo a la gente
que eso ya no va a poder ser así que hay
que pasar esos vuelos pero hasta ahora
hemos hablado de que esos vuelos
permitían la democratización del turismo
claro ahora que caemos en que puede ser
elitista muchas de las cosas que nos
hemos podido permitir hasta ahora
enfermando al planeta totalmente pero
por ello estábamos hablando de eco o
liberalismo que es un poco lo que estás
describiendo ahora no es decir qué
estamos en un momento en el que
realmente habría que replantearse más o
menos todo no en cuanto a cómo se
produce y cómo se consume y
lo que tú estás hablando es que estás
hablando de una ecología una política
ecologista como de una oportunidad de
mercado es decir que de momento la
ecología se reduce a una oportunidad de
mercado para empresas que
generan muchos mucho mucho dinero con
ello es decir que en realidad la
ecología hoy día no está democratizada
es una opción es una elección es verdad
bastante elitista para los que lo se lo
puede permitir pero esto es por culpa de
los estados es por culpa de los
gobernantes porque lo dejan como una
mera opción
a manos de algunas empresas que ahí ven
una oportunidad de mercado pero nada más
que una oportunidad de mercado entonces
está evolucionando realmente por ejemplo
con las cop las cop que vemos que no
logran éxitos o sea metas muy ambiciosas
y alertan lo suficiente al mundo para
que precisamente
de manera progresiva cambien las cosas
yo no soy ni pesimista ni ni optimista
en ese sentido pero creo que hay para
esa situación y está evolucionando le
quiero preguntar a nuestra investigadora
desde el lyon por políticas públicas
porque de esto que estamos hablando la
tributación sería la mejor herramienta
para combinar la justicia social y
bienestar o quizá la más socorrida por
muchos gobiernos lorena creo que esa es
la gran pregunta
en estos temas porque muchos dicen que
los sistemas son positivos e incluso el
por ejemplo en el caso de gestión del
agua la tarificación
pero yo considero que por el momento en
la tributación o los sistemas
impositivos
consigo que aún no son la única solución
consigo que cada una hay hay que
repensar sobre todo porque los
mecanismos pueden resultar muy
desiguales siempre vamos a caer en qué
tipo de tributación y a quienes tributar
entonces pero depende también de la
escala en la que se pueda considerar un
sistema tributario por ejemplo para la
contaminación vemos también por ejemplo
una micro ecología o las acciones a un
nivel macro ecológico es decir también
quien contamina más quien produce más
desechos y quienes se ven más quienes se
ven más beneficiados de todo este de
todo este sistema de contaminación
desechos producción entonces vemos aquí
un importante nivel de compromiso y
responsabilidad entre el mismo marco
desigual que comentaba entre ricos
pobres y evidentemente el rol de la
clase media también que es muy
importante cuestionar cuando hablamos de
justicia social y ecología
y preguntarnos en este sentido quiénes
son los que están en riesgo quiénes son
los que siguen en el riesgo ante ante la
justicia o la injusticia ambiental
lorena me quedo sin tiempo xabi en una
sola frase
que está progresando es para imponer un
tipo de pago por servicios ambientales
por ejemplo podría ser a la agenda pues
ahí lo dejamos muchísimas gracias a los
tres sin duda un reto del que vamos a
seguir hablando con muchas aristas y del
que vamos a hablar seguro en el futuro
muchas gracias hasta la próxima semana
en primera plana
[Música]